hello and welcome to this video
that is uh 4 900
bits video wow
and a funny funny count so
um i'm playing black here in an english
opening with c4 e5
one of the lines that i have played a
lot in the past
oftentimes being able to do a quick
h-pawn push
will seem if we get there
yeah if white now castle short h5 is the
way to go yeah i'm not played here
by my opponent you can still play h5
here but
i don't like this so much in comparison
it's really more pointed if you push the
h pawn
after white has castled already
and without that this is not as
convincing
interesting a very quick b pawn push
if i take it there is queen a4 check
between a4 knight 4c6
d5 b5 is actually
possible i'm not losing material there
takes takes queen takes
bishop a6 like
super tactical stuff takes
actually interesting okay
if it doesn't work it doesn't work but
you will you i mean there was probably a
bit of a weird way to
what i did there was tough to follow but
we'll get there so
you will see now live what i was
thinking about
so b5 if he takes a6 i've got bishop
takes f2 winning the queen
takes now again i'm threatening bishop
takes f2
so queen takes b5 i was thinking and
then bishop a6
should work i just tried to play in the
most
dynamic way possible okay he goes back
which is
probably the right decision now
what are we doing there i can play the
knight
b5 is hanging then though
knight e5 knight takes xb5
and this is probably some compensation i
can also play
b4 in this position b4 takes c6 takes on
c3
stuff like that
i don't want to give up my bishop here
it was would be
a little bit odd
and i'm not a pawn down you know i mean
i can return that
knight takes b5 i just wonder if i have
something interesting here like bishop
a6
knight takes a7 knight d3 check
this actually looks like um an
interesting option
to trying to be yeah keep the dynamic
play up
i can't play bishop b6 maybe if this was
just good for black
possibly yes but this is interesting
um yeah i think he yeah
maybe he can play knight 2 to c3 in this
position
why is that possible
it's the same tactic that was on earlier
so the tactical play here has paid some
dividends i've won the exchange and a
pawn yeah that's nice
i hope i'm not miscounting yeah
so queen c2 what does he want what does
he want to do
some counter play
castling cannot be wrong knight g4 and
maybe i had this
i agree okay
anyway i'm ready for queen a7
potentially
or just take the pawn okay
um queen to a7
that looks very dangerous yes
it was dangerous yeah so it wasn't more
of a tactical game
than anything else but i think it's
important to um
yeah sometimes not avoid the sharp
complications if you feel they work
i tend to do that normally and my games
play more conservatively but
i have explored sharper openings lately
like the dirty harry sicilian will
probably get it on the board
soon enough and this is super tactical
and it's it's just important to not
dodge the complications um if they are
good for you
now here um as i said if they castle
and h5 is a very interesting option
intending
of course just h4 it leads to very very
um messy positions that often are
however good for black for example um
people often respond with h4 and
this is after g5 already pretty clearly
better for black
as the engine confirms it will even be
worse if you look deeper that is just a
very
um yeah a shallow engine analysis here
that
the default djs engine is giving
h3 is also possible after which this
leads to wild complications
that's interesting um he played d4
i took plate 97 now um
you normally meet castles in this
position and then knight f5 and bishop
e3
which i feel is probably um slightly
better for white as the engine also
confirms um now he went before
and i just took it yeah just not
believing this
because there was exactly the line that
happened and the engine confirms that
this is indeed
much better for me d5 and now b5
so there are some lines there to explore
if they take here
this is uh sorry i can just take it
did i did say bishop takes f2 in the
video right i didn't even spot the
discovered
that makes no sense but bishop takes f2
would also win the queen
so c takes and now knight e5
seems to be even stronger that is
interesting
yeah i mean it makes some sense yeah so
what i'm doing here is
i'm getting this thread in the into the
game
and if we look at this this looks indeed
scary
like this bishop f5 okay and that's then
it's a repetition also castles
castles and this is clearly better for
black that's amazing
yeah but okay i'm i'm better developed
a6 will fall and the remaining pawns are
weak
so yeah that's understandable but okay
my idea was this move
and now queen back is probably best yeah
so
if they take here i wanted to play
bishop a6
and that looks indeed pretty dangerous
like this
and the take on e2 and i'm again
threatening this
so this should be completely fine for me
i didn't actually see that here
[Music]
i'm maybe not able to play a discovery
here
like if i do this i mean the engine says
it's possible
like here i have rook a5 yeah exactly
and then i can move it and at the end of
the day the king is on e2
okay well he went back to d1 and i play
knight e5
knight b5 bishop a6
yeah this is not clear if this is the
strongest move actually because
i'm certainly in good shape after this
move keeping the bishop
and i have the better pawn structure as
the two pawns here
are more weak than anything else um
that's certainly not bad
um yeah i think you should take on a7
just like
play play this and and see how he fares
there
it looks good though looks good though
i'm surprised that the engine says i can
just castle that's fun
yeah i understand okay i mean i would
have taken on a7
just to get this back but the engine
slider is cool because knight c6 i can
actually
take um and play rookie area yeah rookie
8.
and then this is like a deadly crossfire
yeah i can maybe take here right no rook
shakes wow
that's nice this is really nice oh sorry
this one king moves is made
and this isn't also not going to end
well nice
nice attacking play okay he went a4
and this is just dropping the house
yeah maybe um knight g4 here
no castle i mean this is fine what i'm
doing here is fine
and here and the queen is even dropping
so yeah that was a pretty
good good win i think thanks for
watching